starwars the rise of skywalker gave fans
plenty of answers to long burning
questions but it didn't end without
leaving a few mysteries unsolved one of
which involved two of the sequel
trilogies most important characters
major spoilers ahead for the rise of
Skywalker in the last journey through
the galaxy far far away within the
Skywalker saga Rey heads out with Finn
poe dameron Chewbacca c-3po and bb-8 in
search of a sith wayfinder which will
guide them to the desert planet x-- ago
within the Unknown Regions they
encounter danger on the way as kylo Ren
continues to force sense and effectively
stalk reg following a lead on the planet
to pass onna the resistance fighters
race away in the general direction of
the long-forgotten ship of a syphilis
ogia bus tune having barely managed to
shake off the chasing stormtroopers as
they head out into the desert the group
speedsters are ultimately hit and
blasted to pieces then they all start to
sink into a quicksand like substance
believing this to be his last moment
before death finn calls out to Rey
wanted to tell her something important
before he can say it though he sinks
beneath the sand while Rey later a spin
what he wanted to say and poe tries
throughout the rest of the film to press
the issue and uncover Finn's secrets the
former stormtrooper brushes them off
leaving the audience without an answer
even after the rise of Skywalker ends
what was he going to say he was sinking
into the desert so maybe he just wanted
to tell ray how he didn't like sand
because it's coarse and irritating and
it gets everywhere okay probably not the
prevailing theory among fans seems to be
that finn wanted to confess romantic
feelings toward Rey however finn actor
John boyega took to Twitter to refute
that particular theory writing no Finn
wasn't going to say I love you before
sinking realistically speaking a romance
between Finn and Rey wouldn't have made
much sense at all with Finn and Rose
Tico having a hint of a romantic thing
in the last Jedi and with Rey and kylo
Ren experiencing a ton of emotional
tension
do you have something a cowl or
something you could put on with a ton of
fan theories running ripe the rise of
Skywalker co-writer and director JJ
Abrams decided to clear the air
surrounding bins big reveal that never
actually came to fruition in the film
according to Twitter user kala Ren
Abrams revealed that Finn's secret is
something as stupid may have already
guessed fin is force sensitive just like
ray rent posted in a tweet JJ said it
meant to him that he wanted to tell ray
he was force sensitive but purposely
left it open-ended
GamesRadar also reported that Abrams
added the open-ended nature of in secret
so it quote could mean different things
to different people we're not entirely
sure why this was a secret that Poe
wasn't allowed to know but Ben certainly
wasn't going to share the info with his
resistance co-general even with all his
ribbing
as we mentioned Finn's force sensitivity
is something that's hinted at throughout
the entire Star Wars sequel trilogy but
most prominently throughout the rise of
Skywalker in the film he was able to
sense when Rey was in danger was somehow
able to pick out exactly which of the
Star Destroyers of the massive final
order fleet was a command ship and felt
Rey briefly died after she defeated
Emperor Palpatine even before all that
finn was able to break free from the
extensive brainwashing stormtroopers are
subjected to in the first order which is
something cinema blend points out as
further evidence of Finn's force
sensitive nature overall this is a much
better explanation than the fan favorite
Wanda Finn wanting to confess his love
for Rey as it ties into everything we
know about finn check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]